hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the thursday afternoon
just before friday monday morning
podcast and i'm
just checking in on you
what's going on how are ya um you know
usually i start my podcast you know what
i mean i just start riffing i [ __ ]
around or whatever but this this this
podcast is different i've been giving
and i've been given instructions
it says bill please mention dates are
going on sale friday morning at the top
of the podcast it is the top of the
podcast
we've added a second leg of the bill
burr slight return fall 20222
tour
uh tickets are on sale now or on friday
i should say you get your tickets at
billboard.com
tour
and uh we added a bunch of dates too i
got to be honest with you some of
um some of the cities that we've added
here i mean these are just the fun ones
it's a couple that i haven't been to in
a long time
and one of a couple that i've never
never even done stand up in so real
quickly starting september 8th this is
right through december 17th i'm going to
read off all the cities this is like
back in the day if you're old
when you'd be watching the news in the
morning right after your paper and
they'd be announcing all the schools
that didn't have school because of snow
um all right tulsa oklahoma houston
texas dallas texas washington dc
philadelphia pennsylvania louisville
kentucky
bloomington indiana
got to go to that one if you're anywhere
near i'm playing in the hoosier dome i
think it's gonna who's your domes where
the colts play where the indiana
hoosiers play where i saw bobby knight
in the indiana hoosiers coached the
indiana hoosiers against the uh
soon to be
ncaa champions that year michigan state
it was amazing
watching him coach and all that he made
me feel better about my temperament i
can tell you that because as big a
temper i have
i got nothing on that guy that guy was
uh he was impressive
he was impressive um
into october i have cincinnati finally
making up windsor ontario minneapolis
minnesota
i was just up there i did a casino ah
there's another juicy lucy there and des
moines iowa i haven't been to des moines
in forever
um i'm a big fan of iowa
hope i'm hoping that the iowa hawkeyes
got a game so i can finally check that
one off the list maybe the uh minnesota
uh golden gophers
i can get something up there i haven't
been to a big ten game out that way
and uh you know being a drummer
um loving slipknot and all of that it
was funny when uh joey jordanson uh rest
his soul
um i remember i never unders i used to
do a joke when i was when i would go to
uh iowa and i would talk about how you
know i never understood the anger
of slipknot until i went to iowa in
february
you know and it was [ __ ] freezing out
and all the crops were cut down the sky
was overcast and it was just meeting
that barren earth
i mean it was literally like a lunar
landscape and i was just like i would go
out of my [ __ ] mind out here
um
but it's beautiful in the summer
uh into november grand rapids michigan
chicago illinois peoria illinois
the birthplace of the greatest who ever
did it richard pryor
um madison wisconsin reading
pennsylvania
and then i'm going to florida
jacksonville florida orlando florida and
a place i don't even know where this is
estero florida
never been there boise idaho to start
off december haven't been there in
forever salt lake city colorado springs
then i end the year new orleans
new orleans austin texas
san antonio texas so um
that's is gonna be [ __ ]
fun
there's not one city in there that i'm
not excited to go to
all right
and i know people [ __ ] on [ __ ] cities
or whatever i like going to all those
all those ones you know
people [ __ ] on jacksonville florida last
time i went down there i went to a
[ __ ]
gun range i ate alligator and i went to
a [ __ ] jacksonville jaguars game
against the cincinnati bengals and i had
a [ __ ] blast
all right i didn't go down there and try
to get some plant-based
[ __ ] uh [ __ ] burger
you know and then go take a [ __ ]
liquid dump in a general neutral
bathroom over there
i
that's something i do in hollywood
but i'm jacksonville i'm like give me a
goddamn gator [ __ ] sandwich and i
would love to shoot that 50 caliber
thank you very much
um and then when i asked for earplugs
they know i'm from [ __ ] i'm not from
l.a but i got the la vibe
you know what i mean i got on a spray
tan i got my shirt [ __ ] you know
unbuttoned down to my uh
my pasty navel
you know
bringing that producer vibe
that's what i do
i like going to those offbeat
the cities people don't go to i like to
go there and look down on people
and go to a a nearby watering hole
talk loudly about how great where i live
is versus no i don't do that [ __ ]
[ __ ] with you anyways so those
tickets go on sale
and um
i am i don't know i'm really excited to
go out to all of those places and uh
see how the new act comes together
um
you know because i have a special coming
out so i have no pressure
especially hasn't even come out yet so i
don't have an other than to replace the
old material there's no pressure of like
when's the next one coming out man it's
coming out it's shot it's ready to go
the powers that be have to decide when
but me
oh freckles i can just put my comedy
[ __ ] shoes up
right
and uh you know just have fun have fun
trying to put together the new thing
i'll tell you this
the shoes
that i've seen over the years in
stand-up comedy
you know when i first started
it was the tail end of the 80s boom
fallout
so there were still mullets
there was still people with sport coats
with the sleeves pulled up
still doing the miami vice thing
this is seven years
after don crockett
and uh the other guy whatever whatever
his character's name was
made that look famous this is seven
years later they were still rocking that
and a lot of them who still rocked that
look their jokes were still from 1985.
right so for some reason if you dress
like that you stop writing jokes during
the second season of miami vice
um if you had pigment there was a lot of
loafers with no socks
there was some silly socks
and uh the guys that were more hip i
swear to god they kept the star search
look was in big
it was a big look when i first started
the paisley shirts the puffy pants with
like the [ __ ]
what are you called pleated
slacks
that would fan out to show that you know
that would hide the fact that you didn't
do your [ __ ] legs
no squats and then they would taper down
in
around your legs around your ankles in
case you decided to moonwalk
to close out your set
um
and then the more the more rugged i
don't give a [ __ ] bar hack guys
they had acid wash jeans
um and then like all white
like reebok
those [ __ ] those reeboks that
everybody had it was weird they were
like chick shoes but then like guys
who knew how to fight and [ __ ] chillers
somehow got away with wearing them and
you wanted to say that those sneakers
are chick sneakers but you didn't want
to take the ass kicking
so you didn't
you just kind of you know watch them go
by like hey are you doing and then they
would walk by and then be like
dude he's got the same sneakers on his
his [ __ ] uh susie [ __ ] firm tits
over there what's going on with that
and that was an actual name of somebody
i went to high school with susie firm
tits um
i think they were from finland
um
anyway and then somewhere along the line
sneakers went from white that's how long
i'm gonna do it they went from white
to black
and now all these years later they're
kind of coming back to white again and
it's sort of like
it's a real weird time right now
where
i remember when baggy clothes
came in yeah that's right grunge started
so there was all of that you know that
flannel [ __ ]
all of that was coming out and me and my
friends were all laughing going like
dude we've been wearing [ __ ] flannels
for years now these are like in style
this is like [ __ ] you used to wear when
you landscaped all of a sudden that was
in
that was in because so seattle bands
where they they were men of the people
and they wanted to let you know so they
would go up there and they would act
like they would they they just got done
[ __ ] you know edge in a driveway
right or a walkway whatever you do by
the way one of my guilty pleasures is i
actually follow a guy on instagram who
power washes
and edges
like walkways up to people's houses
i don't know why i love that [ __ ] so
much i just remember growing up
we never really had the nice yard you
know when i was younger we never did
first of all nobody had a nice shark
there was one
family that had a nice yard
when i was living up on the north shore
there was one family and i remember we
used to look like
they actually had a
[ __ ]
ridiculously green and things the only
guy who gave a [ __ ] about his yard in
the neighborhood and he had he had a
brick
on a house what when it right
and he had like
the greenest [ __ ] lawn i had ever
seen and it was edged perfectly edged
away everybody's yard seems to be edged
but back to i remember seeing that and
we all thought like oh my god
those people are [ __ ] rich
like look at that
like everybody else's [ __ ] grass just
grew there was all kind of all kinds of
that that that [ __ ] crab grass in
there the [ __ ] grew over the walk
driveway was filthy acorns and pebbles
and all of this [ __ ] you know
a snow plow would come in and [ __ ]
take a chunk out during the winter
and it just stayed that way
but these people their [ __ ] long that
their driveway was blacktop which is
hilarious that's just you just basically
coloring in old asphalt but it was black
topped they had the perfect [ __ ]
grass and the edge i never told you guys
back in the day i lived up on the north
shore
the north shore there's the north shore
in the south shore
we were up north when i was really young
i remember there was these kids up the
street this is pre-x games
and they would take they'd steal a piece
of plywood
because they were building houses it was
very over the edge if you ever saw that
movie like new housing
project was just being added down the
street they just blew out the woods and
they just kept building houses
and
they would get like a piece of plywood
that's all it was
a piece of plywood and then they would
get uh some spare tires
they put like two down they would lean
it against it and then they would ride
down on their regular ass bikes this is
before bmx
just regular bikes
[ __ ] you got a child world
child were pre toys r us and they would
[ __ ] jump on these things and land
and what would happen inevitably was
somebody would try you know they
being guys they try to top each other
and keep adding more tires more tires
they added the more severe the angle was
the faster they would be riding and then
eventually the plywood would [ __ ]
snap and someone would get
get [ __ ] up and i used to just sit on
the hill and watch
you know it was a big [ __ ] hill it
was a thing like back then where it was
like
like big kids this is like this was the
beginning of like all of that [ __ ] for
efforts for family if you ever saw it it
was from that neighborhood
and um
me my my my best friend from back then
we would just sit on the hill and we
would watch him and we always made sure
that we didn't get too close
because if he got too close they either
beat the [ __ ] out of you or they'd make
you get on a bike and go do it yourself
so you always knew with like big kids
you always knew that they were doing
something cool but you wanted to make
sure you gave yourself enough of a head
start or like be up a hill so you could
get the [ __ ] away from them
because uh they were [ __ ]
they were [ __ ] [ __ ] let me tell
you a story why i got like i got a
cowboy outfit
for my birthday
i couldn't have been more than like six
years old
and my mother dressed me up in this
thing right cowboy hat
with the little band danish tied it
around my neck and then i had a holster
right and they had this and it came with
one gun
with the mother-of-pearl handle
right a six-shooter it was all plastic
but i couldn't believe it i was so
psyched
and
she sent me outside dressed like that
and i didn't even make it to the end of
the driveway
because kids just [ __ ] roamed around
they were just out there the whole
neighborhood they just like parent
parenting back then was go outside
just go out you just went outside
they did the same thing with pets there
was no [ __ ] leash laws they just let
their [ __ ] dog out and when the thing
came home they fed it
and that was it
so
we will [ __ ]
i don't know so she sends me outside
and i yeah i basically made it to the
end of the driveway
and then this one dude who was like
sometimes cool sometimes not dependent
on who he was hanging out with and he
was with this other kid who's always a
douche
[ __ ] hated that kid
still hate that kid
um they i'm not gonna say any [ __ ]
names they came up the street they saw
me and they just walked right over and
no i know there was three of them i
can't remember who the other kid was
i think he was that other rich kid down
the street that had the apollo three
speed with the slick [ __ ] tire in the
back i couldn't believe it it's like he
had a [ __ ] motorcycle except it was a
bicycle
um
that's how you were judged back then in
the early 70s what your lawn looked like
and the kind of bicycle you bought your
son
um so anyway
i got to the end of the [ __ ] driveway
and i'm thinking i'm looking all cool
and i remember that on again off again
kid
walked right up
took the gun out of my [ __ ] holster
and just [ __ ] like gronkowski spiked
it into the street
and it shattered into a million pieces
the handle did so i guess the rest of
the gun must have been metal
and then him and his friends walked away
laughing
and i just picked it up and i walked
inside
and i handed it to my mother and she
goes what happened to your gun and i
just said big kids
[Music]
and that was it
she should have asked me who did it i
was young enough would have been all
right if i ratted him out i could have
got another [ __ ] gun but i didn't i
just said big kids
and she just set it on the counter and i
sat down
and i was all sad and she made me a
sandwich and that was it
no cell phone video
no [ __ ] uh facebook twitter [ __ ]
whatever the hell you guys are on now
tick tock
classroom
coming to the stage whatever that [ __ ]
is that you guys are on
um
i like that social medias kind of slowed
the [ __ ] down
where it was like myspace and then
facebook and then twitter and then
[ __ ]
vine
then that other [ __ ] thing and then
[ __ ] instagram and but somewhere
along the way it was just like all right
twitter's not going away facebook's not
going away
instagram's not going away all right
everybody can keep [ __ ] jumping
around and blah blah blah blah but at
the end of the [ __ ] day you're coming
back to these
i mean what's wrong with instagram who
the [ __ ] leaves instagram
i mean instagram is the [ __ ] i mean what
do you want what do you want to look at
huh
everything from ass and titties to old
cars
guitars
[ __ ] animals killing each other
i don't know i don't know what else you
need so anyway um
that same kid that was on again off
again cool
i i do remember when they were putting
the pool in at his house
we were watching them and and the guys
had [ __ ] put the concrete in and they
were sitting there like with those
things smoothing it out
and they were in like the deep end which
makes me wonder how the [ __ ] they would
have got out
and uh one of the big kids dared me to
throw a rock into it and i wanted their
approval so i did it
i picked up this rock and i just [ __ ]
threw it
it's a big [ __ ] but
you know i want to say it was the size
of a softball but i was a little kid but
it was a significant size rock i just
threw it there
and the guy just stopped and he looked
up
and he goes you throw that i just went
yes and he goes
get the [ __ ] out of here
[Music]
[Laughter]
and i walked away but i achieved what i
wanted to do i made the big kids laugh
and the next couple times they saw me
they didn't beat me up so that was all
right didn't break any of my toys
um anyways let's do some uh let's do
some of the reads here celtics lost game
one if you're living under a rock like
me
uh i missed all of that game i might
miss game two because i'm doing shows
this weekend but i'll definitely be in
there for game three
um i know miami's a tough team there and
who's kidding who i think golden state's
the uh odds-on favorite who the [ __ ] i
don't know who they're playing
in the western conference finals all
right look at look who it is everybody
it's masterclass
you know with masterclass you can learn
from the world's best minds anytime
anywhere and at your own pace learn to
bbq from aaron franklin skateboarding
from tony hawk
how to throw a rock into a pool by
little billy burr or learn songwriting
and producing from alicia keys with over
100 classes from a range of world-class
instructors that thing you've always
wanted to do is closer than you think
master class master
master master is accessible on your
phone web or smart tv offering classes
on a wide variety of topics all taught
by world-class masters at the top of
their fields
each class is broken into out into
individual video lessons usually around
10 minutes long you know what when i get
a moment in my life i'm i'm gonna i'm
gonna go on this thing and find some
drum lessons piano or something like
that uh members can explore at their own
pace and each class is supported by
downloadable materials lessons recipes
or more hundreds of video lessons
from 100 plus of today's most brilliant
minds are available anytime anywhere on
ios android desktop apple tv amazon fire
tv and roku i highly recommend you check
it out
um get unlimited access to every master
class i don't know why you wouldn't do
this this is this is the good part of
the internet
uh stay away from the demon [ __ ] and uh
this is great for your mind too learning
something new the new studies are saying
it helps stave off dementia if you have
that your family um is that true i have
no idea but this is a podcast and it's
on the internet so there's no liability
and as a monday morning and as a monday
morning podcast listener you get 15 off
an annual membership go to
masterclass.com
burn now that's
masterclass.com for 15 off masterclass
oh look who it is everybody it's roman
you know when the moment for intimacy
arrives
you need to be ready roman ready whether
you've been in a relationship for years
or you're just getting started having
the confidence that comes from
preparation means you're free to enjoy
the moment when the moment comes even
though you are far from ordinary the
truth is that erectile dysfunction is
really common
everybody's doing it man in fact 52
percent of guys age 40 to 70 experience
some form of erector erectile
dysfunction
uh go to get roman.com burn now to speak
to a u.s licensed healthcare
professional about erectile dysfunction
and get 15 off your first month of
treatment ed is more common than most
people think in fact i don't think most
people even think about it
uh in fact 52 of men between the ages of
40 and 70 will experience
some form of
erectile dysfunction and now that i read
that
okay these romans in your head see what
they're doing you're going to experience
it [ __ ] i'm between 40 and 70 is that
going to happen to me and next thing you
know you got to buy their swipes roman's
system is completely confidential and
totally discreet no big logos or labels
on packages take care of your erectile
dysfunction without leaving your home
complete an online visit today to
connect with a u.s licensed health care
professional and take care of it go to
getroman.com today hey all these broads
can go out and get botox in their face
why can't you [ __ ] do a little
smoothie smooth with one of them swipes
there
to get your dick to salute the flag
again go to get roman.com bird today and
if you've prescribed get and if you're
prescribed to get 15 off your first
month of erectile dysfunction treatment
make sure you're ready to have
confidence and control this fall roman
ready
why this fall you're going to take the
summer off
i mean that's that's big time banging
time isn't it the summer
that's why there's so many goddamn kids
born in like april
cause everybody's running around with no
[ __ ] clothes on
i'm telling you keep running around like
that you're gonna get pregnant
that's what they used to say
is that battle still going on
these [ __ ] idiots on the right jesus
christ who gives a [ __ ] if you think
it's the taking of a life how much
harder does the world have to get this
seven billion of us
by all means don't bring any more here i
understand if you think it's killing a
baby
you know what i mean i get it
how do you know that baby's gonna be a
good person you ever think of that
over there on the [ __ ]
over there on the right
um or maybe on the left there's a lot of
people on the left that's another thing
too that's that's the dirty secret
the dirty secret of the left is there's
people on the left that they you know
they're not gonna say don't do it
all right
but they they view it the same way
people on the right do minus telling
other people not to do it okay i view
abortion the way i view heroin
okay it's not something i would do but
i'm not gonna tell you not to do it
okay
listen god put heroin
on this planet for a reason
okay and maybe just maybe
he put strip malls on this planet
for another reason okay i'm just saying
all right
um i'm [ __ ] with you i i don't i
don't give a [ __ ] about any of that
stuff
as far as
telling you what the [ __ ] to do
all right
someone shouldn't tell you to get a
goddamn
i don't know what prostate exam or to
wear a mask whatever your [ __ ] causes
i love everybody who [ __ ] walks
around they don't want people telling
them what to do
you know
but then whenever there's a [ __ ]
problem in society they didn't look at
government and they tell them to fix it
i mean make up your mind do you want
[ __ ] parents or do you want to move
out
you know you want to be [ __ ] snake
pliskin
what do you want to live in 1984 that's
my question all right abortion
uh
what should i look up here
abortion clinic near me abortion news
let's look up news there's gonna be some
angry people screaming all right here we
go
democratic witness tells house committee
men can get pregnant
have abortions
um
all right i don't even need to click on
that
what do you mean men can get pregnant
what the [ __ ] are they talking about
this is like if this is just i don't
know i as a lefty i don't understand
well you know what it is the extreme
left you know what i mean it's like i'm
i'm a fan
of sports i'm a big fan of sports but i
don't call in sport i got to tell you
guys how much i love and hate a [ __ ]
smartphone i swear to god it's got so
many goddamn shortcuts but you don't
know what anything is i barely touch the
side of the thing and it stops the
[ __ ] recording now what the hell was
i talking about
ah jesus christ
i i just i was talking about abortion
then i was talking about yeah the
extreme people on the left
oh sports fans yeah like i would never
call up i would never call in sports
talk radio
i mean i guess i'm glad people do
i'm glad there's people that go before
like the [ __ ] senate or whatever our
house committee
and tell them that a man can get
pregnant a man cannot get pregnant
we're not born with a womb over there
unless
i will tell you this in the future
that's gonna happen
because they can already grow like an
ear and a petri dish the [ __ ] that they
can do is [ __ ] unbelievable
so basically
one of what when
when modern medicine
becomes
you know
gas monkey garage
and you can basically do a body off
restoration
and do a chip foose thing where you're
combining different errors except you'd
combine different genders
there's going to be like women
pressuring their men it used to be to
get a vasectomy now why don't you get a
woman why don't you carry this [ __ ]
thing around
you know what i mean i love how women
[ __ ] about that all the [ __ ] time
they [ __ ] the guys about it it's like
don't talk to us talk to the good lord
the good lord made you that way i didn't
what the [ __ ] are you yelling at me for
i mean i agree with you sounds like it
sucks
by the way
good luck with that
that's a i just love how when women are
going through [ __ ] like that men have to
care about it too as if they give a [ __ ]
what we're going they don't give a [ __ ]
they really don't they don't give a [ __ ]
that's why you know
i you know i love women individually but
as a group when they start bitching i
just can't stop heckling them
it's just too much fun i don't know what
it but that's not really a woman thing
you know a bunch of star wars fans get
together how do you not say something
bad
yeah why don't you grow up you know
your childhood's over man right
childhood's over as i'm still talking
about apollo 3 speeds
you know
yeah i know people are in the nba
playoffs so i [ __ ] about the [ __ ]
lack of defense it's just i'm a [ __ ] all
right i am a [ __ ] wait a minute do i
need a transition
um
all right anyway that's the podcast here
i'm looking forward to watching the nba
playoffs
and uh congratulations to the new york
rangers
with that overtime win i've been missing
so much of this this playoff hockey
condolences out to the [ __ ] toronto
maple leaf fans once again my god
but they are still not considered cursed
because they live in canada
and they like to pretend they're nice to
one another so uh
they don't they don't come at people
like that despite the fact
that the rangers were considered curse
and they went 54 years
all right the toronto maple leafs have
now gone
55 years
right is that what you said um
55 [ __ ] years
without winning it
lyndon johnson was still president
it was before he said
i will not seek
nor nor will i accept
the democratic nomination for president
right
was before that
before we walked on the moon or
pretended to walk on the moon
all right
i mean before a whole bunch of
assassinations
this is before i mean
you think of the [ __ ] that's happened in
55 [ __ ] years
lyndon johnson richard nixon gerald ford
jimmy carter
ronald reagan
george bush
bill clinton
george bush jr
obama trump
jojo jojo biden
jojo over here over here you're giving a
speech come on buddy come over here
worst speech ever um
yeah it's [ __ ] bananas so that's my
thing that's why i root for him every
[ __ ] year
if the bruins are out of it or if the
bruins are playing him i won't root for
him but other than that i have to
[ __ ] root for those guys all right
that's it that's that's the end of this
[ __ ]
um anyway i'm on my way to tampa
tampa florida which means i got to go
down to ebor city at some point get me
get myself a seaguar
um and then i go over to uh west palm
beach there's some [ __ ] after that i'm
gonna have a good time a little bingo
bango in and out
gone and then i fly back
to bingo bango what's that i was
derose's friend put the [ __ ] beer in
the shot
bingo bango um anyways i go all the way
i go back to l.a
and then that's it is this memorial day
no memorial day is next weekend nice
nice nice baby
all right memorial day weekend that's
right we remember all the troops
that fought in all the wars so we could
buy flat screen tvs
and drink like fish on memorial day
weekend don't ever forget all right
don't ask don't tell
uh go get yourself a womb and get
pregnant so you can complain like a
woman all right sorry [ __ ] around all
right that's it god bless you especially
all the women out there you're so strong
and brave all right that's it everybody
um have a great weekend you [ __ ] and uh
listening to the music by the great
andrew themillis and then there'll be a
bonus episode of the thursday afternoon
just before friday monday morning
podcast see ya
[Music]
hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's the monday morning podcast for
monday may 19th
2014.
barometric pressure outside is about
silvery blah blah blah
um welcome welcome to another edition of
this um
i don't know what the [ __ ] it is it's a
goddamn podcast all right
what are you doing right now are you at
the gym
that's what somebody told me recently
you always think we're cubicles we're
not in cubicles some of us are on
treadmills so hello all the people on
treadmills
huh you're running at this point you're
just starting
are you just starting on your treadmills
on your treadmill i should say unless
you're running on more than one
are you that douche is the douche the
treadmill douche in the gym right now
you know that person who for some reason
um do you burn more calories when you go
backwards
you know
or is that some sort of mating ritual
where you get your balls sent [ __ ]
blown the other way and that somehow
attracts the women on the elliptical
behind you i don't know what it is you
ever see these [ __ ] jerk-offs
they run backwards then they'd go
sideways
because they got to have a lot of
lateral movement in the [ __ ] office
you never know when the boss is going to
call an audible and start pointing to
your side of the [ __ ] cubes
right
i think you're turning around yelling at
a cornerback down in the [ __ ] break
room what are you running sideways for
why are you running backwards
you [ __ ] douche and then you fall and
you break your tailbone and who do you
sue
huh
chicago fitness whatever the [ __ ] you
wet
where the [ __ ] you at wherever the [ __ ]
you're at sorry
all right
i you know what i have to admit
something and i have to apologize to the
people of chicago when i pictured
somebody in chicago running backwards i
pictured you know a fat guy with a
mustache and a bear's hat you guys
really have never
outlived that sketch in my i guess in my
world
you know bears and i know nobody says
that there
they might say a version of it but
nobody says that but for me to me you
guys are always going to be those those
those guys
i mean you probably shouldn't give a
[ __ ] what i think but you know somewhere
somewhere there's somebody in chicago
that does give a [ __ ]
you give a [ __ ]
you know what you guys need to do to
lift just [ __ ] self-esteem out there
with that whole second city horseshit
the next generation of babies that are
born into instead of telling them it's
lake michigan just tell them it's an
ocean
michigan ocean or some [ __ ] and maybe
you'll have the arrogance of someone who
lives on the coast and people will start
taking you seriously
what are you going to say right now
chicago huh oh what about our chicago
blackhawks talky
you're not controlling finance
like they are in new york city how many
old people are you stealing from in
chicago right now the way they are in
downtown manhattan
i'm just [ __ ] with you i know chicago
is one of the most corrupt [ __ ]
cities out there
you got to give it respect overtly
racist
[ __ ] with the finance home of some of
the [ __ ] top mob guys throughout
history
and they got the chicago blackhawks who
i will tell you i don't think anybody's
[ __ ] stopping them but i'll get to
that later
if you had the banging downstairs um
as you said that slowly but surely
i'm getting the [ __ ] house repaired i
know what you think about jesus christ
the [ __ ] speaking of lake michigan when
did that water pour into your house that
was like over a year ago yes it was
and it fixed the upstairs but the
downstairs was built like a [ __ ] tree
fort so what i decided to do was rather
than just rebuild what the [ __ ] was
there i decided to knock it all out
and uh start from scratch and build what
the [ __ ] should have been there
and if anybody knows me
and they look at what the dick jokes in
my act you can tell the level of quality
that i expect
from that job downstairs hey is the
podcast loud enough right now everybody
complains like my [ __ ] ears hurt
right now how loud i have this turned up
i think i have it down i don't know what
the [ __ ] deal is i hope it's not
going to be overly loud but every week
somebody goes do it i can't even [ __ ]
hear the thing
um
so anyways this this was my week i guess
i got to talk about nhl first because
the first thing before all the [ __ ]
is i watch my bot my boston blue
uh absolutely [ __ ] blow it
against the montreal canadiens
i'm just gonna pause here for all the
effeminate french guys clapping their
hands together like they're playing
patty cake with themselves
you know with your colorful socks
um
unbelievable
that that was so [ __ ] embarrassing to
lose that's that series
it was so [ __ ] like
the way we lost it it's not embarrassing
to lose to the canadians it sucks but
that was
the first time in a long time
i'm going to go back to the 80s that i
felt that like embarrassed
turning point in the series i'm gonna
say sean thornton spraying the water at
[ __ ]
pk super why would you do that why would
you [ __ ] do that
for those of you who don't watch hockey
we were down two games to one and they
won the first game so immediately we
lost home
home ice advantage whatever the [ __ ]
that means right
so we win game two now it's 1-1 we go
into their building they win game two
they're holding serve
so we come in we gotta win game four we
[ __ ] win it game five can we take
control of the [ __ ] series we win
game five
as paul verzi told me joe torre said the
two most important games to win in a
seven game series he felt was game two
and game five which totally makes sense
because if you lost game one you have to
win game two or else you gotta win for
the next five
you gotta even that [ __ ] right
and then game five you win game five all
you gotta do is win one of two
you lose game five you gotta win six or
seven bill it's simple math well believe
it or not some people don't know it
so we win game five
there's two and a half minutes to go
they're dejected
the canadians are dejected they had the
series by the [ __ ] proverbial balls
over there
and they let the bruins right back in it
and now they're on the verge of [ __ ]
elimination so what do we do
what do we do [ __ ] that we work
one of the people on our team decides to
not only for no [ __ ] reason
spray water
that not only somebody on the other team
their best [ __ ] player
the player that the other people
probably rally around because he's
[ __ ] the best guy in the [ __ ] team
we spray water in his goddamn face
the dumbest
[ __ ] thing you ever remember those
old batman
episodes in the 1960s
where they'd have the guy off batman and
robin is this fit for arcade crusaders
but bla bla neighbor look like they were
[ __ ] dead and the bad guy always did
[ __ ] it up somehow that was the moment
right there
that was the [ __ ] moment he sprays it
in there so then you knew you knew they
were gonna come out like gangbusters i
said it last week i didn't think that
they were gonna win game six i didn't
think we'd get pummeled four games four
goals to to four to nothing
that's what happened they completely
dominated wire to [ __ ] wire dominated
that [ __ ] game so then we go down to
game seven and i don't i didn't have a
vibe either way
are we gonna win are we gonna lose i
didn't know but it's not like the old
days
when the canadians [ __ ] owned us they
don't
they haven't since [ __ ] 1987 despite
what these [ __ ] idiots will write
because they're lazy sports writers not
only has it been even we've actually had
the better of it for the last [ __ ] 30
years or so so
you know it was a 16 [ __ ] league okay
with an expansion six was the tail end
of that horseshit all right can we get
over it already
jesus today i could share myself enough
already it's [ __ ] over
he's dead and so is everybody else that
watched him give that speech
um anyways they're probably not but it
gives a [ __ ]
so we go into game seven and uh
it's the usual [ __ ] i i don't think i
can remember a series where we missed
more [ __ ] open nets
hit more crossbars we were like i don't
know what happened
i don't know what the [ __ ] happened a
couple of our guys couldn't hit the side
of a [ __ ] bar and i still love them i
don't think they need to shake up the
team i love that [ __ ] whenever you lose
a series those you know some some
decisions you have to be made you got to
make some like like you don't have a
whatever we had a bad [ __ ] series so
anyways
um
the game ends and then in a handshake
line lou cheats is telling
a couple of you told a couple you're
supposed to just go through the line and
no matter what grit your teeth say good
game good game congratulations
good luck in the next round whatever the
hey man you know you were great you got
to better me whatever the [ __ ] you're
supposed to say but lucich did that for
a couple players
and then a couple other players he said
i'm gonna [ __ ] kill you which you're
not supposed to do
and uh i just it just wasn't a good look
the whole thing
you know it's funny it's kind of ironic
that i made fun of how the bad boys the
bad boy pistons
the [ __ ] cheap shot artists how they
[ __ ] went out and they ended up not
being bad boys they went out like punks
when they didn't shake the bull's hands
or whatever the [ __ ] they were playing i
don't watch hoop
when they walked off i thought we had
elements of that not saying everybody
charo was a [ __ ] warrior he was
obviously hurt
the guy looked like me on skates by game
seven he was literally falling down out
there but um
but whatever man i don't like that [ __ ]
i don't like the water bottle i don't
like that saying that [ __ ] in the line
so and actually in a weird way ease the
[ __ ] pain
because i'm not one of those fans that
[ __ ] hates that behavior until people
on my team do it i just i don't know i
didn't [ __ ] like it and uh
even if it worked i didn't like it let's
say it worked and we won the series i
don't i don't [ __ ] like that [ __ ]
so anyways uh congratulations to the
canadians definitely deserved it
and as much as i hate people saying uh
real classy they actually won with class
and uh you know
i didn't have a problem with the guy
mocking blue chicha's [ __ ] pounding
of his chest when he scored an empty net
goal
i mean you got to think someone's going
to give you [ __ ] for that and you don't
let it get under your skin and i think
they got under his skin i still love the
guy i'm not [ __ ] on them but they
they got the better of you
and we lost so there you go and that's
how it works so now
the blue blanket rules are now playing
the [ __ ] canadians and they got
[ __ ] smoked in the first one but that
doesn't mean [ __ ]
it's just one loss how many coaches have
you heard say i tell you i don't care
it's 72 a 72 to chill it's only account
for one launch all we can do is try to
learn something from this loss and y'all
going second game and trying to forget
about this one
um which is what i think they're going
to do
and um
my apologies for ranger fans because uh
there's just something about you
i don't hear that banging there you go
that's the guy's downstairs um i just i
don't [ __ ] uh i just i don't believe
in the rangers
there i said it
obviously i believe in your goaltender
i believe in the energy that uh martin
saint martin saint louis however the
[ __ ] you say his name i believe in that
[ __ ] i just don't think you have enough
weapons and then also i think you're
very even with the canadians despite
that seven or two i might eat crow
i did really well in the first round
when the high seeds play the low seeds
oh i was picking them right and left
this just
i didn't watch a lot of the ranges this
year but i'm going to go
just with the history of both teams the
exact thing i told you to ignore when i
was talking about the canadians in
bruins i'm now going to bring up the
canadians history
because i think it applies
in this one
so send your [ __ ] hate mail to me i
don't give a [ __ ] i think it applies
where
they evenly [ __ ] matched
and
because the canadians have their history
and their history of winning their fan
base expects
them to win
and i've seen it in other sports when
you have a fan base that believes like
that they are able to sometime push a
mediocre team up to a higher level i'm
not saying they're mediocre but i think
that they're gonna
it's just gonna be a different vibe
there tonight
when they play
like the fans will have that vibe we're
not gonna tolerate you going down oh two
they just don't do it yankee stadium old
yankee stadium had that sound i'm still
getting used to the new yankee stadium
but the fans know the [ __ ] game they
know what's on the line they're the ones
that yankee fans started that [ __ ] with
two strikes you start [ __ ] clapping
right
they understand the [ __ ] game
canadian fans do the same ranger fans
great fans i would actually say better
fans of the canadians because they've
put up with being a [ __ ] ranger fan
the thing about the rangers
and you got to own up to this range of
fair maybe you don't have to but i feel
don't you [ __ ] you you are
if you're a true ranger fan
you're waiting for the other shoe to
drop
that is the legacy
of the new york rangers so it's a series
like this where they finally turn it
around
i guess well i guess they got to win
another [ __ ] cup because other than
you know you know the deal i don't need
to bring up your past stats other than
1994 i'll do it for people who don't
watch hockey other than 1994 i mean
you're talking like a [ __ ]
talking basically they've won one cup in
74 years it's not a good look
okay the first you know
27 years of that they were only
competing with six other [ __ ] five
other teams okay so um
i just feel that the canadians are gonna
be able to power their way through
and uh somehow win this series i hope
it's a great series two original six
teams you gotta love that and then out
in the west you got the [ __ ]
blackhawks original six first in
expansion six
with the uh the la kings and uh i feel
that that is the stanley cup final right
there whoever wins that
um i don't know how evenly matched they
are
i think the kings might have been a
little tired in that first game it was
only three to one but uh
i don't know i said it a while back the
[ __ ] it's the blackhawks to lose
i think they have a little bit of a
tough time with the kings and then they
just [ __ ] up either the canadians or the
rangers that's what i think now if
you're fans of the other teams you
should be real excited right now because
i don't think i've been right since the
first [ __ ] round
okay
um all right so there's my hockey my
hockey speak
for the week oh it rhymed holy [ __ ] hey
can i hype a couple of things right now
well you have no [ __ ] choice you
gotta listen to it uh the all in comedy
tour the monday morning podcast presents
the all-in comedy tour they're going to
be at hilarity's comedy club one of my
favorite comedy clubs one of my favorite
club owners nick costas
uh
working there and uh i did i say his
name right i know a nick costus and
and then i know nick
is it costas
one of them pronounces it the wrong
[ __ ] way one does the real greek way
so i say the real greek ways and
i just [ __ ] the whole [ __ ] thing up
um anyways hilarity's comedy club
i do not spell his name how about that
is that good enough they're gonna be
there may 28th through june 1st for
seven shows
paul dude i called it verzi
paul i'm not from new jersey versus ah
the [ __ ] doorbell's ringing hang on
all right i'm back you know it's funny
it was just some
[ __ ] person coming to the door
soliciting
just sitting there going like uh
hey good evening sir uh good afternoon
sir i'm uh from the [ __ ] blah blah
blah trying to raise money for
underprivileged kids but man i guess i'm
actually in the middle of a business
call i have to get back i need to get
through and he just goes all right
what was that movie
with that guy versi was just talking
about gabe
well the guy's actually a salesman and
somebody calls his house
and he does basically the same thing and
the guy gives up and he just goes that's
it
that's your pitch
this is how you're selling it and he
[ __ ] gets the guy all amped up to
give him his pitch again he goes damn
that's a sales call the guy's like so do
you want the paper he's like no when he
[ __ ] hangs up on him
i know i've seen that movie anyways i
was hyping uh oh hilarities may 28
through june 1st the all in comedy tour
see them while you still can
all on the same stage this is like when
the temptations were actually the
temptations paul don't say i'm from new
jersey versi
joe
the [ __ ] uh chairman of the board
bartnik
rosebo tailgate legend and cook jason
lawhead cleveland native
jason lawhead go down there if you just
want to see a great comedy show these
are the guys that open up for me
um when i'm out on the road and all of
them are going to become headliners in
their own right and i don't know when
they're all going to share the same
stage again this is like when [ __ ]
frank dean and sammy went out
before they were famous
you know they were in some supper club
going after some wailing [ __ ] and they
said hey what if we all go up here and
see what happens that's what you're
gonna see there in cleveland unless you
stay home
unless you [ __ ] stay home i also have
something else to promote i'm doing a uh
i'm doing a very important uh charity
event
in new york city
all right it's going to be monday
make sure i get this down right monday
july 14th in brooklyn new york
all right it's the uh give laugh groove
is uh i guess the foundation that's the
website sorry give give laugh groove dot
com
and uh they're raising money for seven
children
um and i'm gonna be doing i mean working
with james smith
james got a bunch of fans from australia
uh international comedian uh doing a
little [ __ ] uh co-headlining thing at
the green building in brooklyn new york
with proceeds going to feed my starving
children
uh
oh for god's sakes can i get through a
[ __ ] promo
speak of the devil it's paul verzi hold
on one second
hey paul i'm doing my podcast and i'm
actually right in the middle of hype in
your day i just got done hyping your
date let me call you back
i said i'm doing my podcast i'll call
you right back
okay
all right
um
even he can't hear the [ __ ] podcast
uh what's that
anyways it's gonna be uh at the green
building in brooklyn new york on monday
july 14th i'm working with james smith
and meanwhile uh two phenomenal
musicians remember that band i told you
about drew with a drew where just
everybody in there was unreal are you
guys sitting out there watching these
[ __ ] reality shows who's the next
[ __ ] american i know you just want to
see musicians who are [ __ ] making it
by getting together with other great
musicians and making great music i
highly recommend uh downloading the drew
with a drew album but um
drew from drew of the drew and jp bouvet
modern uh not modern drama the guitar
center drum off winner
berkeley [ __ ] phenom just an amazing
drummer
common thread tour
drummer they're going to be setting a
record for the uh i guess
longest time two musicians have played
together it's gonna kind of be like a
you know like a festival kind of thing
they're gonna be doing that one room you
got a comedy show another room we're
gonna be feeding people it's gonna be
[ __ ] great
uh go to give laugh groove dot com
and come on out okay and now you'll be
seeing me bringing the [ __ ] lumber
uh oh and i'll also be uh feeding some
people too i guess
whatever it's a [ __ ] charity whatever
they need me to do i'm gonna do what is
this here what am i doing here
where is it
where's the copy bill why do you suck so
[ __ ] bad at this
all right it says i got you and james
signed up to do the last meal pack of
each day
which is 4 30 to 6 30 p.m on july 14th
and 4-6 on six on okay the next day but
we're performing only on the 14th
uh still cool with this of course yeah
[ __ ] yeah absolutely all right so there
you go that's what the hell i'm doing
so check that [ __ ] out
okay
back to the podcast
um
all right so this weekend
um i had uh i had a relative graduated
from uh law school so i had to fly back
to boston go right and every time i go
back to boston they [ __ ] built
something else and tore something down
that i loved and then [ __ ] put
something else in place of it and i go
what uh what happened to it this time i
went back and hilltop steakhouse was
[ __ ] closed i was on my way up to
giggles comedy club
to uh
i thought only do one show i did two
shows i should have kept it at one
i went into the second room and i didn't
realize that it was a uh church group
swear to god trying to raise money for
something and
oh did old billy boy munch his [ __ ]
balls on that one
jesus christ
it was a legitimate bomb [ __ ] wire
wire
it just was not a stellar moment in it
like
you ever seen when a plane goes to take
off and it just it's just not at the
right speed and just [ __ ] just clips
the trees that like that's what happened
then it disappears into them you're like
oh maybe they landed safely then there's
the fireball
that was my set
ugh but the other place it was worth it
because the first one
it was magic that was a great do you
believe in magic
um in the [ __ ] main room that one was
great
so
um
i got to work with tony v one of my
favorites and uh yada yada the next
[ __ ] day i go to the
i go to the graduation and you know you
know the deal with graduations you're
like oh my god this is gonna [ __ ]
suck
all right this is gonna be long this is
gonna be hot
it's gonna be hot and long it's gonna
suck sounds like a [ __ ] porno here
it's it's horrific
all right
and uh
pleasant surprise we show up it's
indoors
it's [ __ ] air conditioning
the dean comes out she starts [ __ ]
talking crushes it
brings up some political guy he goes up
[ __ ] crushes it then they bring up
the guest speaker
all right
this is like when a basketball team's
going on a run and everybody's standing
up freaking out an acting all around
here at the zone like palace the [ __ ]
speakers are crushing it then they bring
up the guy that they hired to speak and
he comes [ __ ] walk doctor blah blah
blah blah blah blah whatever the [ __ ]
his name is he comes walking up this is
how we started his speech
he goes
before i speak
i would like to say something
i swear to god that's what he said
that's one of the greatest [ __ ] lines
i ever heard before i speak i would like
to say something and immediately i'm
just sitting there going like oh god
this is going to be at least 47
to 52 [ __ ] minutes of absolute
[ __ ] boredom and uh fortunately i was
wrong
like most of my nhl picks i was wrong
this guy crushed it
you know started talking about being a
little kid and born in [ __ ] nazi
poland nazi occupied poland excuse me
and how the [ __ ] you got out of there
survivor's guilt
you know if you become a lawyer you
don't have to be a [ __ ] content you
can actually work pro bono and help
change the world for a better place it
was great speech
crushed it right now all of a sudden
they handled out diplomas
i'm like holy [ __ ] they're gonna get
this [ __ ] thing done in two and a
half hours this is gonna be great
[ __ ] great then we're out to the
[ __ ] beers and the in the food
and everything's great they hand them
all out and that's it and then the dean
comes back
and inexplicably
starts [ __ ] talking
keeps talking
ten minutes later still [ __ ] talking
and i'm feeling everybody getting
restless
and it's just like what the [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] is this person doing
and then like 15 minutes in it was so
bad
it just started to become funny
i mean everybody was ready for her to
wrap it up in 30 seconds and 15 minutes
in she goes i'm going to tell this this
is just an aside and she told a [ __ ]
side story that had nothing to do with
the other story and all the [ __ ] she was
saying was basically what everybody else
had said
20 minutes in 25 minutes 30 minutes in
and i swear to god dude i like i started
i started getting angry because i was
all the way in up against the wall i was
starting to feel trapped and i started
thinking she's doing this on purpose
this is a [ __ ] power trip
and then mercifully it [ __ ] finally
ended like 35 minutes later
35 [ __ ] minutes later and she didn't
have a clue how much she was annoying
the [ __ ] out of everybody that the the
only thing that was keeping me going was
looking around at people
people were doing everything people were
were just sort of sitting there like
looking out the side of their head at
the person next to him a couple other
people have done that uh what's known as
the confessional pose
where you're seated and you got your
elbows on your knees and your head is
hanging and your hands are clasped there
was a lot of that going on
there was uh other people not even
trying to hide it looking around behind
them like you [ __ ] [ __ ] me that look
not just over the right shoulder left
shoulder too
right
[ __ ] double threat with that
there was people i was right near uh the
section i wasn't near the walls near the
railing and then that was like an exit
right next to me and this one [ __ ]
guy he walked in walked out walked in
walked out walked in the third time and
he literally put his hands out like you
know like when the refs make a [ __ ] up
call it's so [ __ ] up even the head
coach doesn't even know what it is and
then they're talking about it trying to
get it right
and they've come to a decision and they
don't inform the coach and just kind of
puts his hands out like
what the [ __ ] happened what what's
what's going am i getting [ __ ] or my
my
gonna come out all right in this
literally just doing that
and then finally she wrapped it up
it was still a good time it was still a
good graduation but uh
i don't know
that dean i swear to god it was just
like my performance at giggles i should
have stopped
at the first little performance i should
have ended at that it was just
it was horrific okay so anyways
um the next day i ended up going down to
nashville i just realized i haven't read
my [ __ ] advertising yet for this week
god damn it
i went down to nashville for the vince
vaughn wild west
comedy uh
festival the first one
hopefully not the last time because it
was such a great time and i got to play
the ryman theater and i didn't realize
that was the original grand ole opry
and uh
i'm going to tell you about that right
after these messages from our sponsor i
know [ __ ] you too
[ __ ] you go [ __ ] yourself i gotta do
these all right dollar shave club dollar
dollar shave club everybody you know
there are so many things that piss me
off talk about a few things that piss
you off bill okay let's talk about how
the [ __ ] dean should have wrapped it
up the first time and instead goes on
for 35 minutes that pisses me off you
know
there did i reach my contractual
obligation there all right and paying
way too much to shave my face is
definitely up there too right up there
with somebody doing 35 minutes when i
was done with you with your first seven
okay nothing feels better than shaving
with a fresh new blade but new razors
are so ridiculously expensive that you
can't afford to change your blade more
than once every six weeks six months
sorry so you'll end up scraping up your
face with the old blade dollar shave
club delivers top quality razors for
only a few bucks a month
dollar shave club members always shave
with a fresh blade because they get a
fresh pack in the mail every goddamn
week
um they got
they got lots of other products too oh
it's back everybody like dr covey's easy
shave butter
dr carvey's post shave
he's expanding the business
well he also has to have a [ __ ] he's got
a doctor cat doctor i gotta work on my
boston accent dr carvey's post shave
which follows his easy shave butter
um i want some easy shave butter for my
toast wouldn't that be nice
easy butter uh join the hundreds of
thousands of guys who've upgraded to a
smarter way to shave shave time shave
money join the dollarshaveclub.com
join now at dollarshaveclub.com
support this cup podcast
and a great company by going to
dollarshaveclub.com that's
dollarshaveclub.com
all right evoice everybody you're a
business owner i'm assuming that you're
a business owner but automated phone
systems and secretaries are not in your
budget just yet and juggling incoming
calls can really make you sound and look
a little bit unprofessional is there a
solution yes there is here's something
that will dramatically help you and make
you make you more money in 2014. it's
e-voice everybody whether you're a
business of one or 100 e-voice will help
you manage all of your incoming calls
with a toll-free number dial by name
directory and call routing tools your
business will sound like a million bucks
can't take a call no biggie evoice will
transcribe the voicemail and email it
directly to you never be caught off
guard again and with e-voice you can try
it before you buy it right now just for
my listeners and anybody else that
they've paid
money to read this you can get a 60-day
trial to e-voice for absolutely free go
to evoice.com and enter the promo code
bill bill at checkout take charge of
your business and make more money in
2014. go to evoice.com and enter bill at
checkout for your 60-day free trial
that's evoice.com promo code bill
all right one more legal zoom legalzoom
everybody modern technology is
phenomenal
smartphones ipads and other gadgets make
it easy to do so many things but why is
it that our lives seem to get busier at
the same time well when it comes to
getting the legal help you need
legalzoom provides a great solution that
works with your busy schedule let's face
it the legal system is complicated there
are better things you can do with your
time thankfully thank christ legalzoom
is there for you so if you're thinking
about starting a business forming an llc
or getting a trademark what will or a
living trust legalzoom gets the job done
right you'll get the personal attention
you need and they'll help you take care
of all the details legalzoom's been
helping families and small business
owners for 14 years and they received an
a-plus
from the better business bureau call or
visit legalzoom today for an extra
discount enter burr b-u-r-r in the
referral code at checkout that's
legalzoom.com
legalzoom provides legal help through
independent attorneys and self-help
services but it is not a law firm go to
legalzoom.com enter discount code burr
b-u-r-r
all right back to the damn podcast so i
mentioned i played the ryman theater
which isn't in downtown
it's in what i consider the downtown
it's right within nashville predators
play
they got all the honky tonks there and
they got all the play i don't know if
they call them that anymore whatever all
that all the [ __ ]
country music and all that [ __ ] and uh
and right around the corner right off
this little street
is the ryman theater
and um
that's where the original grand ole opry
was at from like 1930-something to 1974
and um
basically anybody who was anybody got to
perform even before then before it was
even the grand ole opry it was a uh
a vaudeville
um space so all these other guys you
know i imagine charlie chaplin i mean he
was doing the rounds he was working the
road buster keaton wc fields they had
his his uh headshot
um hanging in there so that's that
that's how much history this place even
when the people that i'm freaking out
about
the hank williams
you know uh patsy cline and all them
even when they performed there that
place was already legendary
and um
they actually had a couple strips of
wood from the original stage so
everybody you know who came out to
perform had to go and step on them and
just think that you know you know
all these unbelievable performers uh
had been there and um
i'm not gonna lie to you it was one of
the best shows i've had in my entire
career i don't know what happened i went
out there and uh usually takes me a
second to get a little warmed up get a
vibe for the room but i walked out there
and
it used to be a church so they have all
the original pews it was made in like
1898 so they still had all the original
pews
um
i'm telling you right now if you go to
nashville you gotta go you gotta go see
a [ __ ] show there there's a bunch of
other great venues there and stuff but
you gotta go like i heard neil young
played there
um recently i mean that's one that i
would just stop what i was doing get on
a plane
to go to the ryman theater and just sit
in a [ __ ] pew from 1898 and watch
neil young that's just incredible so
somehow a [ __ ] like me told enough
dick jokes and next thing you know i'm
the next guy on the show
so i walk out there and the sun's going
down and up in the upper deck it's
really small a lot smaller than i
thought it was going to be because
people were smaller back then and they
packed them in and there wasn't all this
extra crap luxury boxes and everything
so
whatever it was like a 2000 seater 1800
seater and it was the size of like i
swear to god like a lot of 500 seat
theaters it's unbelievable we're
literally triple the [ __ ] size of
these people i guess so
anyways up top they had these stained
glass windows so the sun was going down
all right
the sunlight is coming through the
stained glass windows it was like the
[ __ ] blues brothers moment
and uh i went out there and it was a
great crowd
and i was on
i started talking they started laughing
and i swear to god i almost did like two
hours i did like an hour and 45 minutes
and i left out like three
huge bits that i'm gonna do on my
special
um
you know you gotta have your blocks
when i put together a new hour and i
feel like i got the uh
i got it
together is you need that big opener you
gotta have the big closer
and then you gotta have like
you gotta have three or four big ones
in the middle you know and then you got
your little ones you give them the rest
then you go back to a big one give them
a little rest a little game take them on
a little ride
um but you got to have like you got to
have the four corners there
to build the structure is how i view it
i don't know i don't know why i don't
have a good science background but
that's how i [ __ ] view the thing
and um
i don't know i i've
had so much fun i'm having more fun than
i ever had doing stand up so i have more
than enough at this point and
that's the only concern i have when i go
to take this thing is i don't want it to
be overly long
but i also want to document those jokes
so i don't know what i'm going to do
either do all of them and then cut the
special and then have those as extras i
have no [ __ ] clue how i'm gonna do it
but you know what it's a great [ __ ]
problem to have so anyways
backstage and you can take a tour of
this
is they have on the up on the third
floor they have the johnny cash room
and they have the hank williams room
and then you go down the floor beneath
it they have second floor they have
that's where all the women's are
because men are better we're above
on floor number three
and then on floor number two they had
like the patsy cline
um the patsy cline room and then uh
what else who the [ __ ] i'm just so bad
at country stars this is really bad
i have no [ __ ] idea who they have
i'm sorry i just painted the whole
picture and then just dropped the brush
just let you guys fall right off the
[ __ ] canvas
i'm sorry i don't remember but it was
[ __ ] amazing i actually went like
actually came out to patsy cline when i
was there i know it's hacky and it's
touristy but uh
it was cool i've always liked her and um
there's actually rumors that she stayed
on the street that i live in
out uh live on out here in la there's
rumors that she actually
rented a house on the block that i live
on and that's one of the really cool
things
to completely make a left turn here
about living in los angeles is if you
are in an area with a bunch of old
houses
there's gonna be somebody [ __ ] lived
in it
at this point hollywood and people
trying to make movies as we're coming up
on a hundred years aren't we
um as far as it actually getting going
hollywood land and all that type of [ __ ]
this you know that there there's a
there's a house
um
i actually read about when it was for
sale
um
somewhere here in hollywood or maybe
it's i don't know what the [ __ ] it is
but basically
the person who owned the house they
owned it during uh prohibition
and then had a pool
and and a cabana
so it's during prohibition and you know
the deal what if they outlawed booze i
mean how quickly would there be a black
market and
you'd be [ __ ] drinking in somebody's
cellar
you know knocking
you know what's the password
the password is uh you know 23's kadoo
or whatever and you
[ __ ] get in right
so um
this person made a bar
uh they turned their cabana into like a
bar and they they just built this little
bar and they don't know how if they
either made their beer in the bathtub or
they had some sort of hookup who knows
what and all these famous people
from way back in the day louis armstrong
humphrey bogart all these people or
whatever
um went over there and drank and they
all carved their names into the bar and
it's still there
so when you went to go look at the house
you could actually go look at this piece
of history and it's actually protected
like they make sure if you buy the house
like you can't tear it down
or sell it or any of that type of [ __ ]
so
um
all of these [ __ ] you know all these
icons they had to [ __ ] live somewhere
so anyways the rumor is
the urban myth on the street that i live
on is that she either on this street or
the next street over stayed in a house
rented it while she was doing i don't
know what so it's kind of cool anyways
to come back out uh
to come out with uh
can you tell i flew today i'm always out
of my [ __ ] mind when i fly my brain's
all over the place
i've had a [ __ ] brutal day i
apologize you know when i when i went to
the airport this morning nashville and
uh it was this extra long line and you
know just stand there and i left enough
time where i could get through it
and um i'm coming up right to where you
begin disrobing and all that [ __ ] right
and um
they end up uh the lovely nia
what's going on how are you
i'm telling my uh my airport story from
this morning
so uh no not even that one
here's here's the story
so i'm standing in line
this long [ __ ]
security line jesus bill get to the
point i know so i'm getting ready to
it's becoming my turn where i get to
[ __ ] take off the belt and the
sneakers and [ __ ] get through the
damn thing and all of a sudden i hear
this person behind going excuse me
excuse me excuse me thank you excuse me
excuse me excuse me thank you excuse me
scares me excuse me jared i turn around
and it's this guy
and he's pushing
this african-american woman who's in her
50s
in a wheelchair
so you know i step aside she goes by
and then the dude behind me
goes
he said he goes i gotta say exactly
where he said he goes they should have
to wait in line like everybody else
that's what he said he went with they
what he went with they so they meaning
are they meaning people in wheelchairs
or black people
i think no i think he meant wheelchairs
because there was other black people
um
uh uh standing in line right so
so i turn around
and i i don't talk to [ __ ] people and
he just it was just so crazy i just
trying to come on man she's in a
wheelchair i go would you rather be
standing up or sitting in that chair
and then there was a pause
and he goes
they should wait in line like everybody
else
like this whole mississippi burning vibe
and that's we know it's killing me
i came up i can't i came up with the
[ __ ] line that i should have said
after i got on the plane what i should
have said
uh what the [ __ ] was it and i already
forget what i gotta have the proper
wording my brain is just not working
today um
oh so i'm like oh now you believe in
equality
it's not equality what is the word now
you believe in uh
ah jesus i just blew it you really are
no i'm completely struggling
no i'm completely [ __ ] out of it
yeah
what the [ __ ] is cuz he's basically you
know this guy he doesn't want [ __ ] to be
equal right but now that she's going by
him now he wants the [ __ ] to be equal
but you know if she went to live in his
[ __ ] neighborhood he wouldn't want it
to be right so he wants equality oh that
was going to say oh now you believe in
equality that's what i was going to say
ah jesus okay
you just looked up and you get what i'm
saying
it's always a great joke when you have
to overly explain it to someone who's
known you for [ __ ] years
ah jesus all right so you see how that
just bombed everybody
maybe it's a good thing i didn't say it
um
that's basically what my second set at
giggles was like
i didn't tell you that nia i [ __ ] ate
my balls
i'm sure you didn't no i did why are the
fi there was one woman's was so
disgusted she wouldn't look at me and i
just kept saying i'm not going to tell
another joke to you look at me and she
she wouldn't look and i kept going i'm
not going to tell another joke she look
at me and she just goes
and continued to look down at the floor
and she was like you know 65 70.
well that's not
exactly your demographic they were they
were
they were a church group
trying to raise money and nobody told me
anything is that true yeah that's that
was my out that's my app that's the
story i'm telling so anyways
so here was my morning right so
i get a car service to pick me up
at lax when i go to land now the whole
[ __ ] purpose of a car service when
you get off the plane the [ __ ]
jerk-off is standing there so you just
leave
you want to leave you're paying a
ridiculous amount of money not for the
ride you're paying the money to leave to
leave the [ __ ] that is lax so i
go down there and there's 10 people
standing there with names and i'm all
excited where's my name where's my name
did i get picked right
am i going to make varsity you know and
of course
my name isn't [ __ ] there
so i'm an entitled jackass at this point
so i'm like you know what [ __ ] that i
just walk out and i go right to the cab
line there's no line there's also no
cabs but i see a cab coming
and the [ __ ] guy pulls up and then
right then i get the text about the guy
and he's like you know
trying to explain to me
that he's in the parking lot and he's on
his way but his english is as good as my
french so it takes a second so i walk
away from the cab
then i'm standing there i'm muttering
these [ __ ] goddamn sons of [ __ ]
you know what the [ __ ]
i want to get out of here i want to go
home i got to record the podcast i'm
being a big baby basically right
and then all of a sudden two seconds
later the [ __ ] town car pulls up he
looks at me i look at him i nod he nods
and i [ __ ] get in the car i'm like
all right see once again bill you lost
your [ __ ] for no reason that didn't take
long at all so we're driving away we're
driving away and i'm in a great [ __ ]
mood i get out of lax i'm feeling great
and then all of a sudden his phone
[ __ ] rings
and he's like hello
what
oh my god i'm so sorry and he goes i
picked up the wrong passenger
so i'm thinking like well you know too
bad for that other guy so the guy slows
down
and he goes we have to go back
and do we were like 10 minutes away from
the airport right i'm like we're not
going back
we can't go back
and he goes no he goes we have to go
back i got to go back and get him you're
in the wrong car
and i'm like well that's not my fault
you pick me up right and then he's
literally starting to turn around i feel
like some little kid
i want to go to the toy store right he's
taking me to go see the dentist
so
i'm like dude you can't just drive me
back he can't do that and then he starts
going you know stop yelling at me and
i'm like i'm not yelling at you like he
thought this was yelling that's not
yelling is
it well you know what you guys need to
up your yelling game because that's not
[ __ ] yelling
so
i i he apologizes the other guy doesn't
[ __ ] apologize to me and he goes i
had to sign and he chose to sign with
like [ __ ] guys last name was like
rancho cucamonga this really [ __ ]
long name
and i'm like i didn't you didn't [ __ ]
show me that he goes yes i did i go dude
are you literally telling me i don't
know what my name is he's like stop
yelling at me i go i'm not yelling and
you're sitting acting like i don't know
what my [ __ ] name is i didn't curse
though
so then i finally just go you know what
just pull over let me out here
so he pulls over and like sepulveda
leaves me off
and he's just sitting there
in the [ __ ] driver's seat
as i as i go to get out
pops the trunk and it's just sitting
there so i leave the passenger side door
open and the trunk open and i walk out
like a total such a chick [ __ ] move
like that's not a man move
um but i did that then i went i got my
nails done
um
it is dude that's that that's a [ __ ]
move
it is a [ __ ] move but there you go who
has a [ __ ] chicks thank you you know
the whole thing about that scenario is
is like his job is to say are you
mr rancho cucamonga
yes i am are you and we're going to this
place right that's normally what they're
supposed to do they make sure you got
the name right i had my headphones on
okay i took my 50 of it all right yeah
because the guy the driver who the
actual person who i it was at least
50 percent of my fault definitely was 50
of your fault because there was a guy
inside holding a sign with your name on
it no there wasn't not at the time but
then he called you or whatever and he
was like i'm coming around and this and
that either way did you hear what you
just said did you hear what you just
said what you said there was a guy in
there holding a sign with my name on it
i said no there wasn't and you said not
at the time
well they called me
it was the thing well i called okay so
if the fire department shows up the day
before the [ __ ] house is on fire and
sprays water on it like is this
his isn't his job being supposed to have
a little bit of timing that's why that's
he is he's supposed to have time and he
should have been there you should have
seen him right away that's the whole
point of it and that other jackass
should have confirmed that you were mr
rancho cucamonga and you were going to
the right place stop staying rancho
cucamonga you said it in the beginning
and i thought it would go with something
different like walla walla
or chubby chase uh
i'm joking but the the so no he should
have checked he [ __ ] up
and then you
he probably told the story to the next
passenger and they both laughed and the
next passenger was easy going and
was was a better person than i was and
gave him a nice but he met but he messed
up he he you're supposed to check
to make sure if you've never met the
person before you don't should have
assumed i was that dumb
that's basically it i should have closed
the door in the trunk i'm a [ __ ]
uh it was a bit of a [ __ ] move
totally well there you go so you agree
with me no i but a [ __ ] meaning like
[ __ ] but not a female necessarily
well it's not fit it's not fair it's a
punk move maybe this no and a [ __ ] just
fitty like having a fit or throwing a
tantrum like a babyish move oh
definitely immature
let's just call it immature all about it
we'll go immature it was an immature
move of you to be like fine i'm not
closing the door or the trunk take that
you're both being like unnecessary
because he should have been like you
know what sir you're absolutely right i
should have double checked with you i'm
so sorry i got 20 bucks on me can i at
least give you 20 for the next one now
he doesn't do all that look at this and
this i think this is why it's called a
check move a [ __ ] move a [ __ ] move is
because
guys
because you guys don't fight for the
most part you guys don't solve [ __ ]
physically
so you guys
you solve it that way because you're
more evolved
as a man you're supposed to like i was
literally
supposed supposed to take off my [ __ ]
headphones and we were supposed to duke
it out right there on the sidewalk and
whoever won that was the direction the
car was going to go in every clint
eastwood movie i ever watched that's how
it was supposed to be done and i didn't
all right
i was like tootsie
that's what the movie was like
so but you still understand that he did
have to go back to get the person who
actually paid for his car
he screwed up but he has to go back and
get the person that paid for the car
he can't call another car
well i don't know what their whole
situation is i don't think you know
anything about the situation because you
don't work in that industry well i just
know that isn't it enough that i just
said i was 100 wrong and that i was a
[ __ ] and i threw a tantrum okay you're
just gonna [ __ ] countersink it and
[ __ ] no no spackle over it i got it
i'm fine i know you had a hard morning
i'm not gonna come in here no the whole
weekend the i swear to god like i was a
[ __ ] idiot this weekend i got on i
returned a rental car at logan airport
and i missed my [ __ ] i missed my
terminal
because i assumed that
something in boston with the sign was
going to make sense which it never does
this is the deal i'm waiting to go to
terminal e
southwest airlines right so they go the
first one
there's two buses one goes to b and c
one goes to dna so i don't [ __ ] that up
i actually get on the right bus
they go to the first one
they're like terminal d
[ __ ] whatever united airlines
american airlines
so i'm like all right well that's not it
d i know it's not d and i was i was
tweeting once again being a [ __ ]
idiot
so while you were driving
no while i was riding but here's the
thing in between terminals that was in
between terminals so we get to the next
terminal
okay i'm gonna bust i couldn't see what
the letter was and it says uh
it says next to you know next terminal
he starts all i hear is the airlines
japanese air iraqi air turkish air
united arab emirates i'm like all right
international terminal blah blah blah
blah and all of a sudden we're going
back to where the [ __ ] i was going to go
what happened to terminal 8 the guy goes
i went to terminally
southwest was in the international does
that make any [ __ ] sense japanese air
turkish air iraqi air southwest
didn't somebody buy southwest though
didn't a bigger airline buy southwest
does that have anything to do with it i
thought i heard that i thought southwest
got bought by some
bigger airline what are you hanging out
with pilots
no
the [ __ ] do you know that i don't know
because i read things i don't know i i
really could have sworn that that
happened
you know what's funny about you you
don't want to get a [ __ ] i want to
bring this up how you don't want to get
a tv in the bedroom because you said it
affects the connection between the two
people i'm keeping it clean here
and meanwhile every [ __ ] night
you know
you're on your laptop so what's the
point why can't i watch the the end of a
game
laying here in bed
rubbing my bulls
watching a game first of all there's
nowhere in here to hang
a television well they used to have
these things back in the day called tv
stance and when you bought a tv there's
not gonna be that no there's not gonna
be a tv stand in here that's no i don't
know that's hilarious i thought i had
fifty percent of this room can it be on
my side of the room then um no
i'll literally block the door to my
closet with the tv if i could just do
what you want to do you want to like
mount it right there and have the door
closed so we can like see it on an angle
i mean that could work that's not a
crazy idea it's not a crazy idea it's
one of the best ideas you've ever had
thank you i'll get rid of that closet
door you're not you're not going to get
rid of the closet i'll [ __ ] open that
goddamn all right let's be let's close
the door let's be serious here i'll play
another man who knows how to fix things
to open that wall up
turn my entire closet
into a [ __ ] tv
that whole wall is a tv
most people make it in an aquarium right
you are like obsessed with lying down
while watching tv i'm tired
i'm [ __ ] tired my brain doesn't work
anymore i have traveled more in the last
[ __ ] year and a half and i'm old now
okay i'm [ __ ] old i forgot i lost
another pair of sunglasses i just
i left my car charger i just drop off
rent a car
i just get out of the car like yeah
we're driving a terminal
i should be wearing those hospital
loafers
and carrying an iv like that like that
should be your sunglasses like i told
you to that all it would take is a phone
call if they were like no we don't see
it then fine you move on but if they're
like actually
yeah i i just went out to the glove
compartment and there they were working
yeah i left my sunglasses in a vegan
restaurant and the dude stole them okay
still about that huh there's something
about a vegan restaurant i don't know
why you keep trying veganism to like
there's something i think it's going to
be morally pure to you no they're like
insufferable people out there no offense
vegans but you know you guys can be too
much with that
oh [ __ ]
hey you know what people wanted me to
talk about jay-z and solange
oh the elevator fight uh whatever the
hell her [ __ ] name is that's her name
i'm sick of jay-z wearing that roger
moore tuxedo we get it
you're [ __ ] cool enough already tom
ford oh is that what that is always yeah
i don't [ __ ] know i always say at
this point jay-z is so famous you forget
he's from brooklyn
any [ __ ] group in a street corner can
still beat the [ __ ] out of you you know
although him with his shirt off you know
i don't know
he's definitely a businessman he's a
yeah exactly
he's he's fine dining he's eating like
steak and wine and like croissants he is
not p90x yeah i can tell you that he
doesn't need to do all he's got the gift
of gab he doesn't need to do all he
doesn't he doesn't you know what i've
i've had enough arguments with people
god bless him
in his roger moore tuxedo did you talk
about the the elevator fight have you
come no i i i'll talk about it oh i'll
talk about it right i'll talk about it
all day
[Laughter]
i thought jay-z regardless of whatever
the [ __ ] he said that sent her off
showed unbelievable
restraint
okay
getting kicked by a woman in high heeled
shoes i've been there okay that [ __ ] it
[ __ ] hurts and he kept taking it to
the hands
and
there was a moment at one i only watched
it once there was a time like one of the
last times she hit him she even flinched
because she was like yeah at this point
he just i deserve to get punched in the
face you see her flinch she spit at him
that was what was really
awful that's what i forgot to do to that
driver this morning that would have been
like
a crowning [ __ ] move no i'd never do
that no no no but you know
their family has problems like anybody
else's family i feel like if anything it
just you know it just goes to show you
that you shouldn't feel bad
when you know your uncles or whatever
start screaming at each other over
thanksgiving that is funny though when
you really think about how many people
are who are judging them
actually there's footage that exists
somewhere of their family fighting in an
elevator it's just they're not famous
and nobody cares who cares
it just gets taped over yeah i feel like
a lot of there are a lot more like
physical fights that happen in families
between siblings and stuff that most
people wouldn't want to admit you know
so it's i it's i i really don't think
it's that big of a deal i was watching
it like salon stop no he definitely said
something [ __ ] up because beyonce
didn't do anything yeah she was she was
standing up with her sister
she was probably like well that's what
happens when you say x y and z
that was her vibe
uh yeah
so but it's not that big of a deal i
don't feel like you know
no that's kind of a big no that's a def
that's that's it's over their
relationship is [ __ ] over and if
money wasn't involved whose relationship
jay-z's and uh the
[Music]
she's
frank stallone
no no she has a really good album i love
her music and she has great style no
she's not as famous as beyonce obviously
and all these dumbass internet people on
twitter are like i've never even heard
of her until now she should be thankful
she got any kind of press this is my my
series just because you don't know music
beyond what's on your top 40 radio
stations they play in the morning while
you're going to work doesn't mean that
this person isn't talented no i just get
annoyed with that first the vegans now
the music lovers
this is the deal the only way she can
make it is if she's in the same group
as beyonce because that's the way it
[ __ ] works there's no way never in
the history
of
two people in the same family trying to
be a solo artist have they ever made it
they always you gotta be together the
everly brothers
the jackson five
the osmonds and then what happens is
somebody breaks out of it and then the
rest of them go back to the dinner table
go on i have an album out too whenever
he's like yeah we don't care
i know i'm your mother i don't care
michael is special
donnie and marie are the best
they're younger than you they're cuter
than you and jesus likes them better and
that's what happens and you're [ __ ]
so
the only move she had was when beyonce
was on the way up she should have been
in destiny's child look at me look at me
on the other side of the fence just
calling off groups here bill she was
well was she in that group she was like
i thought it was chemicals and uh that
chick from uh nicole from uh uh one of
the roller skates tootie wasn't she in
that
they're [ __ ] just naming black people
now yeah um
no she was like a backup dancer she went
on tour with them when she was younger
she had an album when she was younger
she got pregnant she moved to like i was
oklahoma i was a backup dancer i was
remember that ac dc
that acdc video who made who when i had
all the anguses up there i was one of
the angus she also she also i didn't
really people i didn't know i wish i did
she also wrote quite a few of beyonce's
songs and like co-wrote some of destiny
child song too so you know she's she's
got other talents yeah things you know
yeah she doesn't need to be as famous
she's like that chick
and i say hey
what's going on her name is linda no it
isn't she's the lead singer
it's jessica or something it's not you
know i'm right i don't know what her
name is four non-blondes yeah lead
singer linda perry recently married to
sarah gilbert from roseanne did you know
that who played darlene
they're married the last time i saw
linda perry not the last time like i see
her but i saw her wait isn't that
blonde's chick isn't she like [ __ ] she's
got to be my age probably what's she
going around that little girl for what
are you talking about sarah gilbert's
older than i am i saw this show the
other day she's like 12th that's because
she looks great
but
but no i saw linda perry at the rest of
the vegan restaurant in question
oh yeah i hope she didn't leave her
[ __ ] sunglasses or a top hat
do you not you like her
linda parry oh because i have a problem
with white people with dreadlocks
damn it
you [ __ ] snuff that right out
you're too smart for your own [ __ ]
good
she doesn't have them anymore
yeah but she had a songwriter
at the time i didn't think nia doesn't
like white people with dreads
i just feel like she doesn't like wets
weds i just feel like
i don't know dreadlocks are a very
particular cult i don't know maybe they
don't that style doesn't belong to
anyone anymore would you consider it an
offshoot of blackface
no
no
i think it's like you know white people
that don't want to do their hair and
like think they're super um like tapped
in to like rasta reggae music and like
what if they really
really
[Laughter]
what if they really really really love
weed
that yeah that doesn't mean anything
that they actually normally do really
really really love weed with their
goddamn hemp necklaces and whatnot so
isn't that a commitment to the lifestyle
that's not all rastafarianism is though
it's a religion
no it isn't yes it is google it not in
this country
well
when are their holidays and how come we
don't get the day off because it's not
it's not an american thing you said it's
not not in this country exactly no i was
joking i was just being an idiot but no
it's not a like an american or whatever
religion
no it isn't no but this did aren't there
enough rosters over here that they could
start complaining we could get another
day off
yo man how come the jews got all their
days off september
sorry worst [ __ ] jamaican accent ever
is that where rastafarians come from
i don't know all i know
is i wouldn't [ __ ] with any of them
i don't believe in magic do you believe
in magic but i do with [ __ ] those
people i wouldn't [ __ ] with them
it's not i saw nothing magic i've
watched are you thinking of voodoo yeah
because that's not the same thing listen
it's all raiders of the lost ark not the
same thing at all listen they used they
still they still use boring and weird to
you aren't they
yeah i went there yeah yeah
yeah i'm threatening you yeah i'm
threatening you
um stamps.com everybody you want to do
whatever it takes to make sure your
business runs efficiently course you do
but constant trips to the post office
can definitely get in the way eats up
valuable time that you could be spending
on growing your business instead so
bring the post office right back to your
desk with stamps.com you don't have to
be a postal expert stamp.coms makes it
easy buy and print official us postage
for any letter or any package using what
you already have your own computer and
printer then
just hand it to your mailman
or mail person
it's just that easy join over join the
fox doing so great join the 500 000
small businesses that use stamps.com and
never have to go to the post office
again i use stamps.com to send out all
my dvds and my posters for all the stuff
that i wore myself out with at the end
of the show i'm a [ __ ] if i can use it
so can you right now use my last name
bur for this special offer no risk trial
plus 110 bonus offer includes a digital
scale and up to
dollars free postage don't wait go to
stamps.com before you do anything else
click on the microphone at the top of
the home page and type in bur b-u-r-r
that's stamps.com enter bur
that wasn't bad was it very good hey you
know what i forgot
i think is now the
ultimate pc we've covered it all mail
carrier i know but that job's not going
to exist in a couple of years they're
phasing the whole freaking thing out
um back in the day they had our mail man
um all right wait a second i needed to
promote something here oh people oh i
haven't got to the [ __ ] questions
this week
um oh people always ask where can i
email
the podcast this is where you can do it
at bill
sorry bill at the mmpodcast.com
once again bill
at the mmpodcast.com
okay
there you go and on twitter you can also
if you want to look up some of the clips
and [ __ ] at the mm podcast and mmp
in both things is capitalized
now they have to rewind both whatever
the [ __ ] thing is all right stan hope
um tons of emails about the stanhope
episode lots of kind words from
listeners insane amounts of requests for
him to come back you know i tweeted him
to say thank you for the flowers but he
never tweeted me back but he has also a
gazillion followers so he probably
didn't even see it yes he did he brought
you that uh
the nice uh it's not a bouquet he bought
you a potted plant yeah he bought you
the flowers that keep giving yeah the
little floral management i put it out on
my little balcony for some reason he
thought that you weren't going to like
him like he was going to be
i don't know what like a bad influence
he would have loved him came in
absolutely killing this [ __ ] leisure
suit he looked great he was wearing a
leisure suit i missed him in a leisure
suit now i've
i've never met him but he sounds cool
he's really funny so oh yeah i'll meet
him really funny is an understatement
he's been like
you know anybody who says that's the
funniest guy in the country for the last
at least eight years i i would never i
would just say you have great taste in
comedy
now get out of my way i'm trying to find
my car
oh entitled bill this week all right
dear billy faithful
you and nia seem to have a great
relationship from the listeners point of
view
uh couples always play that if you could
cheat with anyone who would uh why did
you have to show up for this who would
it be game
i'm asking you this if you could have
one woman
from all of history i don't know when
people say that like you have any idea
antoinette
what what like joan of arc look like you
just what the way she she was painted
women were [ __ ] ugly back in the day
oh stop it and the guys were everybody
was shaped like a refrigerator that's
why i hate those old photos when your
pictures the paintings when you go there
all those [ __ ] rump roasts everybody
just [ __ ]
how many wars did you win how are you
like get on just go walk around the
castle a couple of times yeah
what about fine art or whatever and plus
those people were just there yeah living
the life eating good food and being
serviced and they just sat around a
bunch of pasty fat thighs and asses they
didn't have to do anything is the people
out in the field those were the people
who had great bodies
but the aristocrats yeah they're just
kind of you know there turned into mush
as you like to say
yeah
well well they should have painted the
poor people because the [ __ ] fat
asses in the castle
they were a mess no wonder they wore
robes
you know
everybody else is walking around with a
[ __ ] leaf over their junk
all right i'm asking you this
if you could have one woman from all of
history be absolutely in love with billy
twinkle toes oh is this for you who
would it be no it's for you
oh they're writing it okay assuming nia
isn't in the picture for non-violent
reasons
who would be your girl imagine you have
60 seconds to give your answer and it's
going to stick for all
and eternity
uh thanks and go [ __ ] yourself um
60 seconds is on the clock i know what's
[ __ ] up is it's just what's great
about this is it isn't just who do you
want to bang i'm gonna have to live with
this person when the looks go
and that you want them to be in love
with you and you have all of history
all of history for me is
every hot woman i've seen since the 70s
one choice
one choice
there are some 70s women that you bring
up i feel like you
might still well i liked all the charlie
you know what i liked all the charlie's
angels but could i live with them
kate jackson was i think the cutest one
i loved kate jackson with that smokey
voice and when she was on the rookies
how much how much time i got left you
think about 30 seconds 30 seconds 25.
who else did i like another smokey voice
with some curves was the chicken the
beginning of uh
cheers
then she was on fat actress and she
looked like oh kirsty alley yep
she's really beautiful she's gorgeous
she is a beautiful woman
very beautiful [ __ ]
um so cursey alley circa cheers
kate jackson circa charlie's angels but
you only get one i know there's gotta be
somebody else i know somebody else this
is too [ __ ] quick
no no no i got ten seconds
you gotta count down ten
nine oh [ __ ] pressure
marion rush
what marion rush who's marion ross she
played the mom on happy days
i had nothing i had to go with something
funny do i get to choose
nope but i'm here i know you're here but
the question wasn't for you
summer baby
summer baby
sunny sunny baby sunny baby
deer
deer billy
i could admit that's a [ __ ]
ah no that's actually good he has abs
and he can sing you know so you get the
movie star and the rock star
yeah jesus christ all right summer baby
dear billy sbf 1000 you get it because
i'm pasty you know some [ __ ] wrote me on
twitter saying like hey bill i went to
take a picture of the ryman but you're
so pasty it just looked like a bunch of
clothes
and uh which is true i'm definitely
pasty but here's a little tip for you
people out there want to take a picture
during a show
why don't you use a [ __ ] camera
you know i love how it's always me and
my pigments fault rather than you and
your phone you're taking a picture with
a phone
it's a phone
it's a camcorder it's a text and device
it's something you can watch porno on oh
and it's also a camera
it's trying to do too many things it's
wearing too many hats
you bring a [ __ ] camera in there it
can capture me and all my lack of
pigment all right so quit blaming me
it's your [ __ ] phone
all right
big plans for this summer i know you
live out there in the perfect climate no
i don't i don't it gets hot as hell here
in the summer time and it catches on
fire
um
he said for people not soil he said well
that's funny but what's on tap in the
months of june july and august you ever
think about getting a jet ski
and hunting sharks on the coast do you
have a pool what are you excited for um
i am excited to not kill sharks
i think it's disgusting that people do
that [ __ ] and i think it's disgusting
that people swim in the [ __ ] ocean i
think it's you shouldn't do that [ __ ]
that's disgusting it's reckless
uh i don't have a pool
what am i excited for um
i'm doing mike johnston's another one of
his workouts and i'm leading with the
left hand
one of his drum exercises i'm leading
with the left hand and it's getting
[ __ ] stronger every day and uh i'm
having a hell of a time playing drums
i'm excited to ride some motorcycles
this summer
i'm excited to take my dog on a hike i'm
excited to not [ __ ] work for a couple
of months after i take my special other
than doing the local clubs out here
to build up my next hour and of course
i'm also doing the uh
i'm doing that um benefit
on july 14th at the green building in
brooklyn new york with jimmy smith
um
james smith sorry and um was jimmy smith
jimmy smits
[ __ ] nypd blue
um
all right last thing girlfriend
constantly gets hit on
not jesus christ hey nia
come in here for this one
no i'm talking to the entire landscapers
real quick jesus christ
all right
the landscaper they're not the
landscaper these are the people who
actually plant the [ __ ] tomatoes
as you can tell all i do is tell jokes i
don't [ __ ] know to do anything else i
can't even drive myself back from the
[ __ ] airport i lose my sunglasses
like an old man i i have caretakers at
this point uh dear billy red balls i've
been with my girlfriend for around a
year
and i've noticed that lots of other men
hit on her i mean a lot
now this happens almost never all this
almost never happens when i'm around
well that's respectful
but she tells me at least a few times a
week about a creepy stranger who
approaches her or cat calls her i have
to say it makes me pretty uncomfortable
but proud at the same time the weird
part of all this is that while my
girlfriend is asian it's only older
black men that hit on her
wow that's weird she must have a [ __ ]
fat ass or something no disrespect
now we're both in college and i just got
back from four months studying abroad in
france
while i was there she told me about a
guy in a parking garage that came up
behind her and groped her i told you
she's got a fat ass
a guy who stopped traffic in the middle
of downtown atlanta just to say what's
up and a tutor who flat out asked if
she's single and started to insult me
without ever having met me
oh my god
that's [ __ ] awesome i'm sorry but
that's hilarious he's hitting on one of
his students finds out he has a
boyfriend hey guys sounds like a douche
how soon before that guy gets fired
um anyways cashiers at starbucks drop
comments too and she says they always
stare at my chest
is she trying to make me jealous
um
well have you conveyed to her how that
makes you feel
you know just saying not for nothing you
are gorgeous i understand why people
look at you i mean
i looked at you i didn't look at you
like a creep
you know i just thought you were
stunningly beautiful and i had to talk
to you now here we are in this
relationship but uh
i don't know i don't know why she's
doing that
do you not tell us she's beautiful all
the time are you not giving her
something that she needs so she's saying
look at all these other people who want
me
or is she just out of her [ __ ] mind i
don't know let's keep reading now for
the summer she's also in a study she's
also in a study abroad program but in
barcelona
ah jesus christ
who is this right now i any [ __ ] it's
just like uh
you guys are living a hell of a life
here while they were out in a little
group exploring the city one guy with
her tried to hold her hand and tried to
play it off is just a joke
ah jesus i can't get mad at that we've
all had a big swing and a miss
what are you doing oh no no just kidding
i'm just kidding
um anyways i don't know why she tells me
about these things but she knows oh she
knows it makes you feel uncomfortable
if i was ever there with her i doubt
this would ever happen but we're
unfortunately long distance until july
i'm kind of worried because she's under
21 but now she's in europe she's able to
drink and i'm scared someone is going to
try and take advantage of her and
there's nothing i can do am i crazy for
having this bother me so much
i don't know what i can do to stop it or
even if
or even if it would stop when i'm with
her
how do i keep them away
let me ask you a question sir
do you love this woman
you know is this the woman that you
think you're gonna be with
if you have a definite answer
yes then you need to talk to her about
this
okay and just say listen you're a
beautiful woman and i'm just gonna have
to accept the fact that when i'm not
around guys are gonna ask you out the
same way i did okay but
for my own sanity i would really
appreciate it if you didn't tell me
about it
okay unless obviously somebody gropes
you then i want to [ __ ] find the guy
and kill him
um if your answer is no
um you're studying abroad in france
i just came back from there
the most beautiful women i've ever seen
in my life
per capita are over there
you're going to be foreign you're going
to have a [ __ ] sexy accent to them
cut your [ __ ] losses
go down and buy some [ __ ] condoms and
have at it
all right
that's that that's my suggestion i hope
i didn't go too quickly with that
but uh how do you keep them away you
can't keep them away and when you date a
beautiful woman you just you have to
accept on some level that guys are going
to hit on him kid on them hit her on her
and you can't get mad at that
they're beautiful you did the same
[ __ ] thing
you can't tell me before you didn't get
to know her as a person if you really do
love her that when you looked at her you
didn't just went god
you didn't something
you didn't say something like that
so um
yeah you know
i don't know what to tell you
you're gonna have you're gonna have to
find a middle ground if you're going to
stay with this woman you either have to
[ __ ] uh
yeah you got to convey that it's bugging
you and then make peace with the fact
that it's still going to [ __ ] happen
on some level all right
but uh she's really young and you must
be really young too and you're both
going to
countries where they [ __ ]
because you know that's what's to do
over there
i'm such an idiot but
i'm just saying you know
what are you gonna do
well that was awful sorry i just got off
a [ __ ] plane i tried i tried
um
that's my advice if if you know what i'm
jet lagged here if [ __ ] somebody has
some better advice
just write it in to the uh
bill at the mm podcast.com
and i'll try to maybe do a better job
next week that's the podcast for this
week sorry now i got the hiccups
that's it everybody go [ __ ] yourselves
have a wonderful uh wonderful week and
i'm gonna go watch the [ __ ] ranges
play the canadians see
you